انعقدت في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضه اعمال
القمه الثالثه والاربعين لقاره دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي وفي كلمته الافتتاحيه اكد
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
اهميه التكامل بين دول مجلس التعاون وبشان
العلاقات مع ايران اكد ولي العهد السعودي
ضروره التزام ايران بمبدا حسن الجوار
وبالمواثيق الدوليه كما شدد على اهميه حل
القضيه الفلسطينيه وفقا لمبدا يحل
الدولتين واقامه دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
بناءا على المبادره العربيه وبالنسبه
لليمن اكد ولي العهد السعودي ضروره ايجاد
حل سياسي لانهاء الازمه كما قال الامير
محمد بن سلمان ان دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ستظل مصدرا موثوقا لتزويد العالم
بما يحتاجه من الطاقه
تاكد دول من الضروره وجود حل عادي ودائما
قضيه فلسطينيه قارات شرعيه الدوليه مبادره
السلام العربيه بما يقفل الشعب الفلسطيني
حقه في اقامه دوله مستقله على حدود 67
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وتاكد المملكه
دعمها الكامل للجهود الامويين راميه
للوصول الى حل سياسي شامل الازمنه اليمنيه
ماشيه مع عباده المملكه لانها هذه الازمه
وفقا للمرجعيات الثلاث كما تؤك المملكه
النوويه والتعاون مع وكاله الدوليه الطاقه
الذريه والمحافظه على مبدا حسن الجوار
تامر المملكه المصادر الطاقه
الهيدروكربونيه
مهمه لتربيه الحاجات العالم لعقود القادمه
تجاه العالم والرجال القادمه
وفي هذا المجال قامت المملكه باتخاذ
العديد من الاجراءات حيث اطلقت مبادره
السعوديه الخضره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
مفهوم الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون والعديد
مبادرات الهادفه للتنميه المصادر الطاقه